welcome to this video playing for sure
for sure is this somehow it correctly
pronounced i know from france and we
play em english i'll bring the English
Defence f3 really this does not look
good the question is can i make can I
make any use of it probably this wasn't
the way to go I know he know he can play
what I have three and then open the
position that's that's cute amazing
check
no it's playable I mean f3 is in this
position j-just weakening and not
helping much but it does not seem to be
totally disaster the media disastrous
immediately okay maybe just here would
like to get the dark squared Bishop 66 m
this is probably a good idea i wonder if
i should play h6 first okay i'll start
start with this it's useful anyway um I
cannot sacrifice no no yeah need to
check it like on on h2 but I have this
Bishop e3 deform there must be some draw
back to f3 relief okay here we'll play
Bishop f2 I guess anyway to make use of
all that probably not but I can maybe
try to ask this Bishop wet is intending
to go maybe I can okay it's going here I
was thinking if he goes to sea for
something I might have rook e8 first
what about play Queen d6 here by the way
looks okay h3 is really a tremendously
ugly maybe he must do that g 3g anthesis
of course also possible I can just win
this pawn now on deform but is it
helpful checking first then tem is
getting is getting see 70
is getting c7 back at Sam so I maybe I
shouldn't take really adds as good as it
looks at first Queen h4 g3 the check and
then back maybe maybe the check and then
all the way back to the aid check
keeping the deep on attacked if i take
it with the bishop though I know rookie
to a half c5 so I can I actually
threaten to take it with the bishop and
then play see 5 ok and this was probably
quite good c5 maybe before I don't know
ok try to make sure that I don't use the
UM the C porn I can still take hear them
27s nice i know i have six check it's no
problem yeah I don't know should I take
here it's probably not bad so let's do
that not sure how to take it be here
yeah yeah that's probably okay Ruby
seven Bishop g4 is good I will the check
first and then Bishop g4 and yeah okay
this trade is also ok a check can you
should reform or to e5 now d 4 is good
this also has Bishop g1 maybe the right
moment
yeah here or maybe maybe look to a form
not sure just take it like that and
cheater the bishop hungry forum shops e5
my can be a jerk and just go back silly
Brooke a three days some night xe5 okay
this uh didn't really help check time
morning
check this was helpful specialized
resign with one minute down yeah this f3
move was really a bit weird young it
looks like very weakening nothing
totally terrible but half it looks
strange to me playing at 3am the thing
is maybe I cannot really use it so much
I mean d5 what I played is I think not
really anything right because he can
take and play 597 d4 and then F for next
zone this is okay for white you know
maybe d5 is only looking weird but what
definitely is weird that he took twice
yeah hmm just giving like a good
position and sorry in the computer here
stockfish points are bishop d6 and
castles this is in fact even better
getting my development going quicker
yeah Queen to channel so but ok black is
comfortable here but nothing terribly
special here it gets it gets serious
yeah here I could could play it very
very central fashion but the problem is
that there's always this coming at the
end and the White has Bishop b3 with
pressure on the f porn so this is not
even good for black or not even a
smidgen of an advantage such as nothing
until I'm really just a pawn up so it
was better yeah from technically face
there are certainly some alternatives I
will see three years somewhat better
okay I was keeping a pretty distinct
advantage in any case
check yeah okay this was promoting the
blundering the night he didn't have any
great moves though probably needs to go
here yeah it's the opponent it's also
very um yeah nicely coordinated position
for black so I don't think he has many
chances to to save this game okay thanks
for watching